[Musique]
le tx appétit l'apam le batoura le
parata le dosage le rôti ce ne sont que
quelques-uns des pins parmi l'immense
variété qui existe dans le sous
continent indien
les trois pins plupart que là c'est le
pain naan le cas paty et le prat a peint
anne s'est plutôt fait autonome meilleur
plusieurs types de pain qu'on trouve la
cuisine indienne ont professé haut avec
l'indien l'on peut faire cela villiger
vaste choix au restaurant sendou de
montréal on prépare le nan de façon
traditionnelle
c'est simplement de lure la farine
blanche nommé un peu de réussir medley
ont médusé lover sel l'huile et on
mélange tout ça chacun là les recettes
le pain naan et de consommation courante
dans plusieurs régions dei centrale et
d'asie du sud
on recommande quelque chose de
restaurants indiens en commun le pénal
ou le tx a pâti l'année beaucoup
pratiqué en restauration dans les hôtels
dans les mariages
que plutôt qu'un raison parce que tout
le monde peut pas avoir un faute en
dehors à la maison c'est certain elle
peut le faire aussi au poil
mais ce type on retrouve pas la même
température à la maison un poil qu'un
temps doux la pâte est collé à la paroi
brûlante du four en terre cuite qui peut
atteindre 315 degrés celsius il gonflera
et sera prêt en 30 secondes
certains villages posséder pour
communautaire
à défaut d'avoir un temps doux nanda
nous donne quelques conseils pour cuire
un penan dans la poêle à la maison ça
commence déjà on peut pas prendre les
îles complet avec le chaleur du poêle
la deuxième méthode de cuisson consiste
à cuire un côté dans la poêle et l'autre
sous l'élément chauffant dufour de
braizat donne plus la route de talent 2
parce que ça va brûler la has et
wolinski comme résultant pour vous un
penan parfait c'est quoi flas pris un
peu ce qui est bien russie ne pas trop
sec non plus quand louvre puis c'est
très bien cuit à l'intérieur aussi le
canadien est parfois garni de graines de
pavot ou de sésame
il peut-être farci de noix chez ou de
fromage
mais dans cette partie du monde le pain
le plus consommé et le chat pâtit il est
élaboré à partir d'une pâte de farine de
blé dur à ta riche en protéines et en
gluten chapatis temps group +1 c'est
vraiment ceux du blé antilles on prend
le pari nabeul de blé et en mains de
l'ump de l'eau tout simplement
c'est un peu plus léger c'est le pain
comme le père blé entier ici ça vaut
laisser comme ça pour 30 minutes pour sa
offert une petite boule comme les herbes
folles de golf
puis vient la cuisson on peut faire
directement sur le gaz comme ça ou sur
une plaque métallique ne me tabac les
sags ont ça se dévore aussi quand ça
gonfle à l'intérieur elle est belle la
serre voilà on l'enduit souvent de
beurre clarifié
nier sera resté mon d'autres points
comme le pury le bateau rats sont frits
ils sont associés à une cuisine de re
amène les patous rares marche beaucoup
seuil des points chauds
c'est très commun dans les bras ou dans
les rues très mince et feuilleter le
parata et le dépeint du plus populaire
des cuisines indienne pakistanaise et
afghane
il est appelé rotich à nay en malaisie
c'est quelque chose qui est vraiment ça
prend du temps à apprendre pour fait d
un bon petit chalet un banc pratta faut
qu'on travaille jusqu'à 7 c est comme ça
la plus con travail c'est mieux les
produits financés comme ça après avoir
passé deux heures au frigo on fait des
petites balles avec la pâte puis on
étire et après ça on fait rouler comme
ça comme ça ça fait des différentes
couches
[Musique]
non on fait écraser un devient comme ça
c'est ça qu'on veut mais non voilà pas
tout feuilletée j'espère que vous êtes
fiers de vous la wii parce que leurs
titres et le protège fais pas ça souvent
une fois peut-être deux fois par année
c'est tout l'étiopathie nous en fait un
instant si longtemps c'est plus denses
comme pain photo cc le baise moi je
trouve c'est bien réussi beaucoup plus
celui-là on c'est beau et c'est réussi
et c'est très bon récit beaucoup nos
impôts
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]